my name is Martha sellers I'm the
cashier at Walmart and I've been there
11 years I love my job I love new
customers and I live with coworkers I
had been taking care of myself without
adult answers and I needed a job
I need to get out of the house get out
from under big breach and I applied
everywhere never the first done set
called me back then hired me when I
asked for more hours they would cut my
hours floors and kind of laughed at me
and I'm starving and I can't pay my
bills my credit cards have past due my
cars on the blink
I didn't have money particular gas in
the car to get back and forth alert when
you're so hungry that if you're bending
over to pick up trash on your job
because that's part of your job you
can't walk past it and you get so
lightheaded you think you're going to
pass out
my Christmas tree I water it keep it
watered and then I move it to the tongue
of the trailer
I don't put lights on it or anything I
have no electricity out here but my
Christmas tree so I'm always ready for
Christmas it used to be my favorite time
of year it's not anymore
you